let's get to the mail bag for the week
you can email info davidpackman.com if
you have something to say hopefully
um it doesn't have to be positive but
maybe at least uh thought provoking in
some way or uh interesting or I don't
know something a Dottie wrote into me
and this one came in via Facebook and
Dottie said you're an idiot first word
is already wrong as you know almost a
requirement in these emails that you use
the wrong you're you're an idiot you
don't talk about our president that way
president Trump is our president then he
said exactly what he should have said
those people that are in jail are not
criminals they're innocent people that
were put there just to show face in the
Democratic party so don't talk about
President Trump he's exactly right and
he's not confused about anything you're
the one that's confused examine your own
mind open up your mind and realize what
you're saying he's a smart ass and the
best president we've ever had
one sentence
I guess no punctuation
complete cult
commitment
to Donald Trump and mega trumpism
this is someone who will vote Trump in
2024. so if we're thinking about what is
the math what is the what is the
constituency that takes Trump down
it probably doesn't include Dottie
and that's okay that constituency may
still exist but
this is what I don't even know where
we're going this is what we're up
against and it's really really scary
Michael wrote In
with a slightly more grammatically
correct but still factually vapid
uh statement called leftist hypocrisy
Michael wrote the sixth January I'm
sorry the January 6 quote rioters did
not break the law they were allowed in
even invited by Capital police as seen
on video
they are Innocent but you don't care
because you're a demo rat wrong you're
suffering tedious and happy to jail
political opponents not me you must have
my politics mixed up with someone else's
you never called for antifa Arrested
even though they did millions in damage
way more than the protesters on January
6 also people died in the antifa riots
the only death at the Capitol was Ashley
Babbitt killed by Rogue cop yet you
don't want him jailed just walk free
like nothing you are a hypocrite and
it's clear to anyone who isn't a demo
rap
so this is crazy
uh but a few important points I think to
mention
I have never said
if someone committed a crime
don't prosecute them I have never said
that I have always said
if there were crimes committed during an
antifa demonstration or a black lives
matter demonstration no matter who did
it whether it was a member of antifa to
the extent that there's membership if it
was a part of be whoever
if there is evidence that a crime was
committed charge the person I don't care
about the affiliation I also know
that the 700 defendants from the Trump
riots are obviously not innocent and in
fact courts and juries have adjudicated
them guilty in already dozens if not
hundreds I don't know where we are in
the process of all those cases I am not
happy to jail political opponents in
fact I'm against it
I I don't believe in jailing people
because we have different politics I do
believe that if you want to make an
argument that pre-trial detention in
this country is a problem by the way
it's an argument I've been making for a
decade you were the one who has to be
consistent because all of these right
Wingers only now care about pre-trial
detention for defendants they never
cared about it before they never cared
about it when it was people with whom
they disagreed politically so they are
the Hypocrites not me uh better
marketing Spencer wrote in about the
left and better marketing and says David
do you think the left needs to Market
and message their policies better
Medicare for all doesn't seem to be
driving people to the polls remember
more people supported gay marriage once
it was called marriage equality
and more people supported gun control
once it was called ending gun violence
Medicare for all seems like a government
program like a welfare giveaway maybe
call it guaranteed health care or
something similar Beth Spencer so
there's two questions here the first is
about the best name for a Health Care
System where everybody has coverage
I I quite frankly don't care what you
call it I'm totally open to the idea
that Medicare for all may not be the
best term
I don't know about guaranteed Health
Care who's guaranteeing it I don't know
but just focus group it let's figure out
what the right term is does the left
need to better market and frame a
thousand percent and I've talked about
this so many times before the left loses
so much on framing we've talked about
pro-life we've talked about tax relief
we've talked about uh you know what
medical freedom but used in a completely
dishonest way uh yeah there are so many
examples the left does need help on that
it seems like a worthwhile thing to uh
to put some money into quite frankly
Fritz wrote in and Fritz is happy
because there's finally a progressive
voice on the radio Fritz writes hello Mr
Pac-Man and crew I grew up and still
live in rural Indiana I currently live
in Goshen Indiana which is a micro City
I've been to Goshen radio is still a
major part of Rural Life in Indiana it's
free and people spend a lot of time in
their vehicles yes we have public radio
and it's okay but there's so little
testosterone on the public stations in
comparison to the bombastic crap on the
right that leftists are just saying
really arguments seem weak or
unenthusiastic please note I am not
saying you're some sort of Super Macho
Man for Progressive values Fritz I don't
think anyone thinks you're saying I'm
some kind of Macho Man I don't know that
that's necessarily a correction that was
necessary uh but at least you're willing
to be argumentative and quite frankly it
works in this area you're willing to
engage with them and where they are on
the radio in rural in Indiana it will
make a difference or at least it will
stir the pot a bit thanks again Fritz
Fritz thank you uh we you know we do the
radio show some people may or may not
know this
we don't make any money from the
syndicated radio show and I'm not saying
this like oh I have tears in my eyes
even though I'm a big strong guy I'm
just saying we've decided even though we
don't monetize radio like our income
comes from the online podcast YouTube
Etc
we produce the radio show at our expense
it's a loss okay it's like a trump
business it's a loss
um because we think it's worth being on
in a lot of these rural places where
there are very few options for a
non-right-wing or religious uh radio so
we're doing it and uh we're gonna
continue to do it Irv Rodin Irv says
David it always amazes me when right
Wingers call you a communist insultingly
yet are devotees of Tucker Carlson and
the Fox News cabal who idolize the most
communist country and its leader Putin
in fact so much so that they are
featured in virtually all of Putin's
propaganda campaigns aren't they the
Communists they will never accept this
analysis ever ever ever
they will say
uh it's not about defending communism
it's about the left has a vendetta
against Russia for no reason or what
they will squirrel their ways out of it
but it is interesting that many of the
people that Trump was most impressed by
are from countries that don't exactly
have market economies Russia North Korea
we've seen it all uh good luck
convincing them Sam wrote in about the
death penalty and says David I have to
disagree with your views regarding the
death penalty it is definitely true that
many people have been convicted
incorrectly where the evidence is
circumstantial no death penalty is
warranted but when you have mass murder
I assume they mean Mass murderers like
John Gacy Jeffrey Dahmer and mass School
shooters like Nicholas Cruz where there
is no contradictory evidence there
should be executions these people serve
no function and are of no value to
society to the dismay of the victim's
families Nicholas Cruz was just recently
sentenced for Life perhaps if your
daughter had been one of his victims you
would have a different point of view
this is so important
Sam is not wrong
if my daughter had been a victim of one
of these school shootings
I might have a different point of view
but that would be out of a desire for
Revenge
and we shouldn't have a justice system
based on Revenge so
Sam is actually making my point
which is that is not a good
justification for the death penalty the
fact that if I was in this situation I
might want revenge by saying kill them
it wouldn't make it any more right it
would just mean I want revenge so super
interesting and I think Sam not making
the strong point that Sam thinks he or
she is making a rod wrote in about Trump
sweating and says I believe that Trump
is sweating because he may be diagnosed
with ADHD which is treated with ritalin
and sweating as a possible side effect
this fits his profile well if it is true
that Trump is medicated for ADHD
that medication was not uh revealed in
the medical release about the
medications that Donald Trump takes now
would it be a big shock if Trump had
hidden elements of his health uh record
no it wouldn't because he put something
out claiming he's 6'3 and weighs 239
pounds and we all know that that's not
true uh but as far as the record is
concerned Trump is not on uh Ritalin and
not being treated for ADHD write in info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say uh questions or welcome comments
are welcome demands for Corrections when
they are accurate are welcome as well we
will uh see you on today's bonus show
we're off Monday in observance of the
Christmas holiday uh and we will be back
on Tuesday we'll see everybody then or
on the bonus show momentarily
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday paired gives the
two of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and paired
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way a of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below